ATISSA BANUAZIZI:
So I'd say that one
of the most important things for
communication instructors who
are partnering with
technical faculty
is for everybody to have
a shared understanding
of the assignment genres
that you're working with.
So if students understand
who they're talking to
and what the purpose
and the context
of the communicative act are,
rather than just saying, like,
it's an oral presentation,
as though that's
some kind of descriptive
term in any way,
the more they understand
that, the better off they're
going to be, because then
you can start to ask them
what, practically
speaking, is likely to work
for getting the message
across to that audience.
But that involves that,
like, all the instructors
be on the same page.
And so sort of sitting
down with the instructors
at the beginning of the
semester or beforehand,
and just getting from them
a really clear understanding
of how they conceive
of the assignment
and how they
conceive of the genre
and how they conceive of who
the students are talking to
and why, makes all
the difference.